Mr Trier was the gruff No Nonsense
superintendent of the New York City
apartment building in which Monica
Rachel Chandler and Joey resided on
friends and he factored into the plots
of five episodes between 1995 and 2001
portray Mr triger was a prolific and
highly recognizable character actor Mike
haggy known for his mustache a Chicago
accent and his tendency to play working
class characters before friends he
played a cable TV station employee in
waynew and the best friend in overboard
after friends he appeared in Brooklyn 99
Shameless and in 2022 he was part of the
main cast of HBO's somebody somewhere
the star of that show Bridget Everett
announced on Instagram that hagate had
died on May 5th 2022 writing a beloved
character actor his love of his hometown
of Chicago and his family were the
cornerstones of his life according to
TMZ haggy suffered a negative reaction
to an antibiotic used to treat a leg
infection and he fell into a coma the
actor was 67 years old